[Music]
we've got renee in knoxville tennessee
hey renee how are you
i'm good how are you good what's going
on
all right well um
i am
me and my me and my boyfriend have uh
recently become engaged congratulations
and
thank you
and
we both agreed on the amount that we
would spend on the honeymoon and the
wedding
but as we are like
you know spending the money on the
different things that we need we're like
wow this is a lot of money um so we were
just wondering like we're trying to be
responsible with it while also at the
same time because code's taken so much
away we're still trying to have like a a
good good wedding so
are we being responsible with our money
or
or not like are we overspending on our
on our wedding and our honeymoon when
you say you said we realized wow that's
a lot of money you mean the amount of
money you budgeted or you mean you
started actually pricing things out and
the
the quotes you're getting are more than
you expected which one are you referring
to
i would say it's just like as we were
spending the money we were like wow
that's a lot of money and because maybe
one of us have a fully funded emergency
fund
we were like okay yeah this is a lot of
money should we just be putting it into
our emergency fund or
you know we we are cash flowing
everything everything so
yeah it was just like as we're spending
it we're like
this is a lot of money what's the budget
what's the number y'all came up with
ten thousand for the wedding and the
honeymoon okay cool and you do you guys
have any debt
no no we're both debt-free okay what's
your you said y'all haven't got a fully
funded emergency fund yet separately or
together or whatever what's that amount
between both of y'all
between the two of us well he had six
thousand i have two thousand so together
we have eight okay cool
and uh what's your income
he makes about two thousand a month i
bring home about seven
okay
well
here's the thing renee um
ten thousand dollars is a lot of money
for
you know a week essentially for your
wedding and um a honeymoon when you're
going oh my gosh this is a short amount
of time when you look at it through that
lens and then when you go for a wedding
budget it's actually a really
conservative budget
in the wedding industry now we're not
going to use either one of those
lenses to be the only lens we look at it
through and what's interesting about
what's interesting about money is um yes
it's it's a physical thing but it's also
emotional and so
even if if george and i said yeah i
think the amount of money you're
spending is fine you're cash flowing it
you do have some emergency fund going
you can continue to build that up you're
kind of it you know setting aside this
this money for the wedding and it's not
unreasonable you're not being a diva
renee like for a wedding and a honeymoon
that's very conservative in my opinion
but
the butt here is that if you're not
comfortable with it
if you've got a check in your spirit
well it's your money and it's your
wedding and you can change the budget
you can reign it back and say hey we
feel better about eight
or we feel better about seven or
whatever
we're never going to tell you not to
not to save money because that's always
a good idea to set you up for financial
success but i will say that in the grand
scheme of things you guys are debt-free
you're smart you've got a good income
and your budget is not unreasonable at
all i think you're fine but it doesn't
matter what i think because if you feel
checked in your spirit about it then
then you're welcome to change that
george what would you say i mean this is
this is one of those it's very funny i
just did research on this because
someone asked on reddit and i haven't
you know
read it don't get me started with reddit
well here's the thing christy i thought
this is a good question they were asking
you know what is the right budget for a
wedding and there's no ramsey parameter
i can't google and say well dave says no
more than ten thousand that doesn't
exist what he says is pay cash right
don't let it be a huge you know portion
of your world and it sounds like you
guys are doing this on your own there's
no family helping out here
and so again like christy said do what
makes you comfortable but also realize
you're not a bad person weddings are
just expensive the whole industry is
basically a scam because they can charge
whatever they want people go well a
venue is what a venue costs so if you
can find ways to trim that's fine but i
want you to have a great time i don't
want you sitting there worried the whole
day that you're you're like counting the
minutes and comparing it to how much
dollars that cost going well it's a
thousand dollars an hour to throw this
party for everyone so i want you to do
it on your terms and if you're doing it
for anyone else other than yourselves
that's when i would go let's rethink
this yeah and the other thing i love how
you said that renee i mean uh george
because renee we want you to enjoy it
like this is your wedding day you don't
want to be thinking about the the dollar
per hour cost and i just want to say it
again
ten thousand dollars in the wedding
industry
for i want to reiterate wetting in
honeymoon
he's really conservative that's really
conservative you guys have done well
you're not you're not being crazy here
and you're cash flowing it and so um
here's what i would say and this is in
light of george's advice i love how he
said this
you guys maybe revisit that budget and
if you're like yeah 10 is good we've
done our research we can you know 10 is
what we want to spend we're comfortable
with it then don't look back
decide on 10 commit to 10 and don't
think about it make it work within 10
but then be like we feel good about this
we're going to we're going to be excited
about this day and what we've committed
to because um you know george i'll tell
you when it comes to
like house projects like uh improving
our house we're actually doing something
right now we're paying someone to
restain our deck it's kind of worn down
i can matt and i can come up with a
number we feel good about but when it
comes time to spend it i'm still not
excited to spend the money now i'm
excited to spend money on clothes shoes
earrings fun stuff but house stuff i'm
not and and a wedding is obviously more
exciting than house stuff but sometimes
when you get into those higher dollar
amounts
it still can be emotionally hard to let
go of that amount of money even if you
know you want the thing like a stained
deck or even better
an awesome wedding and so there is
something to it of just committing like
we're commit we're committing to this
amount of money we feel good about it
and we're not going to look back we've
got the money we're not going to feel
guilty
money should be enjoyed you guys and so
yeah renee i love your your question i
love how conservative you and your
husband are being a future husband or
being and um and i hope you have a great
wedding i think you're being really
smart about it well done